本というのは先人の思考を時を超えて
学べる裁量のツールですね。僕は目から
入る情報、耳から入る情報をかなり
セレクトしてると思います。知恵を
生み出すためには知識が必要だし、この
知識は書物によって残されてるわけじゃ
ないですか。青木サの人生額100回聞い
たら豊かになる話。
え、今回のテーマは成功者が読書の重要性を語る理由というのが今回のテーマなんですが、青木記社長の考えをお聞かせください。
[音楽]
これはね、もう私は出版社の代表と会長もしてるんですけどね。
アチューメント出版27年やってきました
けど、本というのは先人の思考を時を超え
て学べる裁量のツールですね。要するに
思想や思考、その哲学あらゆる現象って
いうのは思考の現れなんですよ。そのだ
から成功してる人の残した書物というのは
やっぱり僕はとても役に立つと思います。
それから研究だよね。研究所、例えば成功
者の共通校例えばナポレオンヒルという人
はアンドリーカーネギーからこれから成功
していく500人。この500人の研究を
したわけだよね。ずっと追跡調査をして
いって無学歴でちっちゃな街工場しかやっ
てなかったフォードが不号になってくわけ
ですよね。エジソンにしてもそのなん
だろう。まだ成功する前の人たちの共通
どうしてその成功していったのかっていう
研究でしょ。それが報告書として
まとめ上げられてローブサクセスとして
アンドリーカネギーに1400ページの
報告書が上がったわけだよね。で、そこ
から350ページンアグローリッジ富を
どうしたら生み出せるかっていうところで
まとめ上げた書籍が出来上がったわけだ
けどこれがエビデンス。まさにエビデンス
の書なので実証済みの成功理論なのでだ
から1億冊も世の中の人はこれを読んで
くださってるわけだよね。私は23歳の時
にナポレオンヒルの成功哲学に出会った
わけですよ。
こな間だ僕のインタビューチューメントの放士でね、出すキャピタルの吉村秀さんに対談してもらった。彼で
5000億円ですよ。なしたの。
5000億。でも彼は
歳の時にセンカンのグローリッチに出会ってるわけですよ。私
歳なんですよ。この差は大きいね。はい。この
10年は大きい。
でもやっぱりね、全てのあらゆる富というものは思考生み出されているんだという事実アイデアなんですよ。知恵なんですよ。だ知恵を生み出すためには知識が必要だしは書物によって残されてるわけじゃないですか。
だから、ま、今世界的に大富豪の
ウォーレンバフェットさんも本当に読書、
よく読書されますよね。読書の習慣を持た
れてやっぱりね、先人が残したそういう
クオリティ、本当にその目には見えない富
の厳選になる知識や知恵が書物によって
残されている。これは学ばない手はない
ですよね。私はベンジャミンフランクリン
という人の本物2冊。1冊は跳躍。ま、1
冊は解大で出しましたけれどもね。
当たり前のことを書いてるんですよ。でも
それを実行することが大切ですね。だから
あ、こういうことを大事にしたからこの人
はこれだけの富を得たのかと。で、世の中
の成功者が1番にあげることって誠実です
からね。あなたはなぜ1台でこれだけの材
をなしたんですか?はい。私は誠実であっ
たからこれだけの富を得ました。これが
第一の答えなんですよ。2番目ははい。私
は自精神があったからです。自己鍛錬した
からです。これは2番目ですよ。自精神で
3番目の答えはい。私は社会性があった
からです。ま、人との違いを認め、力を
合わせて生きていくことができたってこと
だろうね。4番目の答えはい。私は近べで
あったからです。やっぱり近べに働くと
いうのはやっぱり罪をなす基本なんだろう
ね。やっぱり生け物の人はやっぱり罪は
なせないんですよ。で、1番最後にね、
あなたはなぜこれだけの富を得たんですか
?はい。私はパートタンに恵まれたから
です。じゃあこの5つを実行すればいい
わけじゃ。で、これも書物に書いてあるん
だもん。僕もそれを書物で学んだんだから
。かが僕の考え方って僕じゃないんだよね
。僕の考え方は好典的に多くの書物や多く
の尊敬する諸戦の影響から出来上がった
ものであって生まれながらにこの考え方を
持っているわけじゃないんですよ。
この考え方を作り込むっていうのが大事で、そのためで
1番いいのは1番連1
番役に立つのは両承を読むってことですよと私は思いますけど。
ありがとうございます。
ちなみにその本で読んだことをその単なる知識でその場で終わらせることなく自分の血肉にしていくま意味のある読書にするポイントみたいなのも教えていただけますか?
[音楽]
ま、僕がやってきたのはノートを用意していいと思ったことはそこにノートの方に移すこともやったしそれからよく線を引いてね、でこれはいいと思ったものに対しては線を引い
で、そしてそのキーワードは記憶するよう
に、反数するようにして、キーワードは
自分自身がやっぱり自分のものにしたよね
。だからある日自分の考えなのか先人の
考えなのかわかんなくなっちゃった。人は
その人が考えている通りの人間になると。
Rチンエールがそう言ったんだけど、でも
なんかもう自分の言葉になっちゃってるよ
ねとかさ。もし人生に限界があるとしたら
それは自分が定めた限界だとかさ。これ
だってやっぱり人が言ったことが自分の
言葉になっちゃってるんですよ。いや、
もっと言うと辞書に書いてあったことが僕
の思考になっちゃってんですよ。だ、理念
とは何かと、理念とはある物事の本来こう
あるべきであるという根本となる考え方と
かこういう風にこう定義されていると
なるほどとだ僕はじゃあ理念根本となる
考え方僕は誰のために何のために経営する
んだろう。あ、やっぱり人を幸せするため
にやってんじゃないかと。それが理念系に
なってったわけで、え、儲けるためじゃ
ないなと。だって何のために設けるのって
話になるわけじゃん。愛する人を幸せに
するためでしょ。その愛する人の対象が
家族だけじゃなくて社員やお客様や臨人に
なるまで広がるわけじゃん。そうすると
やっぱり自分を愛するようにあなたの隣人
を愛せようとバイブルにはあるんだけど、
やっぱりそういう考え方が根感だよね。
だ、これも全部バイブルの影響を受けたり、いろんな書物の影響を受けて何千
冊も本を読んでこの考え方になっちゃったわけよ。
ちなみにその読書の習慣というのは幼少期から終わりだったんですか?
あの、確かにあったと思います。
ただギリシャ神話とか子供の頃読んでたの
は、ま、図書館からもよく本借りてきたし
、家が貧しかったからいつも本買って
もらえるような家程ではなかったんで、ま
、僕の年代の人も多いと思いますけど、
図書館からよく帰りきて読んでたね。あと
辞書好き。国語辞書大好きだったから本当
によく読んでました。あ、それすごい
プラスなったと思ってる俺。辞書になんで
辞書が好きになったのか不思議。
本当自分でも
なんかね、定義されてると賢くなったように思うんだよな。余分なこと言わなくて済むじゃん。で、自分の中で整理されるから人と接していてもこの人ずれてるかずれてないかって自分の頭の中にいろんな定義してるからその定義に対してこの人ずれてるとかって判断できるわけよ。た絶やすい儲けほど難しいものはないとかっていう。それキーワードがバンと入ってるとあいつ絶安すい儲けを追ってるなとかね。
いや、面白いんだよ、これ。それから急な
話には気をつけなさいと。そうするともう
急にね、今週締め切りなんですけど、これ
すごい儲かるんで買いませんかとか、これ
気をつけなさいとかあったなとか、もう
こういうの全部自分の思考で抑死になっ
てるもん。うん。安田善治郎さんのこと今
話してて、何事も順序を持って定めるべし
とか。で、ものすごく僕順序うるさい
でしょ。契約かわす前になんか仕事に入っ
ちゃいけないとかすごい順序厳しいじゃん
。だから守られてるわけよ。だ郎さんで
会ったことがないのにあの人が残してくれ
た言葉に僕は守られてんじゃないの。渋沢
Hさんだってそうじゃない。企業はね、
個人の知理をこう図るものではなく、広く
財力と知力を集めて社会に公益な事業を
なすべきであると。これ渋沢さんが
おっしゃったことがいこうやって入ってる
んだよ。で、もっと言ったら俺教育基本法
まで覚えちゃったもん。教育とは人格の
完成を目指し平和的な国家及び社会の形成
者として心理と正義を愛し個人の価値を
遠び金労と責任を文じ自主的精神に満ちた
心身ともに健康な国民の育成を期して行わ
なければならないっていうからその通りの
研修プログラム設計してそれを寄り所とし
て33年3日間の研修やってんだよ、俺。
いや、これユニークでしょ。でも文字
じゃん。文字に僕は生かされてるわけよ。
本を読むっていうことは共養も高まるし、
品性も高まるし、領所に触れるっていう
感じなんだよな。ま、僕ね、今ふっと話し
てとて思ったけど、目から入る情報
コントロールしてるわ。若い時から耳から
入る情報もコントロールしてるわ。
というものもそうだし、お付き合いする人
もそうだけど、僕は目から入る情報、耳
から入る情報をかなりセレクトしてると
思います。これは僕がおそらく今良い
人生きれている秘訣かもしれない。よく
YouTubeも見るのよ。自分の
YouTubeも見てるけどね。だけど
良いYouTube見ますよ。だ、本物か
偽物かをパンと見極めて、あ、これは偽物
だなと思ったらスルーしちゃう。うん。
すぐやめちゃう。それも早いだ。本もそう
なんだよ。あ、これなんか役に立たない
こと書いてあんなと思ったらやめちゃう。
だから本当にいいものを熟毒するっていう
タイプかな。
ま、結局読書によって人格が作られたり
触れることによって価値観が形成されてき
た。それが自分が実態権を持っているので
進めるんじゃないですか。完潔に言うと
そういうことだと思います。いいなと思っ
たらチャンネル登録是非ね、してください
。あとあの、え、高評価、またコメントも
ね、是非。また次回のYouTubeで
会いましょう。ありがとうございます。
感謝します。